okay so this is number nine
we're trying to menuchi
strike to the front ushero to the rear
we're trying to strike this area the
heart because
the heart is run on electricity and
we're trying to thump it
hard so it stops knocks the
the rhythm off that stops electricity to
the heart
and kills the person sorry to be so
harsh but it's a martial art and i need
to just cover that point
why we're while we're aiming here
so mini choo choo ski
pros and cons that's we've talked about
before
you can go forwards it's your choice
back
the first part is the same
you then loosen the front hand
pull it all the way and it sort of
raises up so it's
coming here
it's level now with my heart so it means
that
because i'm practicing it myself and i'm
doing suburbia
i have to have a target so i'm leveling
it out
some people they pull it
and it's far too low as you can see and
then they have to tip
tip the end up okay so i have to tip the
end up so this is
again what i've learned from
myself other teachers will have other
opinions
pull to the end right to the end don't
put your finger on here
that's the fault it's a different arm
the body is sideways
you look down your jaw it's like looking
down a sight you're using your joe as if
if it's a sight
look first get to the end look first
ski
your body feels like it's rocking like
this
foreign
sometimes i do that
just to go back to repeat it again and
again so i'll just show you why
what i do in my own way
okay
it just brings me back to combine makes
you feel a little dynamic
gets the adrenaline going
all right so there's a lot of mistakes
that can be made in this
and the strikes here not here
end the strike here level with your
heart
pull to the end don't say oh i can't get
dead get to the end
turn
it's a hammer punch
the other hand might be this way but
your hand is this way so it's
don't have too big a hole here okay
don't have this big hole here it means
it's weak
these are the two fingers that hold the
josh
and the ken so these are the ones that
need to be on it
if you have it like this you're doing
the opposite
so they could knock that out your hand
if they were quick enough with the joe
no gaps
another fault another weakness
some people they thrust and they
they don't it doesn't pass the body
it doesn't go possible so if they did
hit
your jaw hard and you wasn't holding it
it could damage you
plus you haven't gone to the full
remember the the skis
at this point this is wrong
this is also wrong you haven't allowed
the full impact of the movement
after all these years i still have a
weakness of telling you what to do
and don't let myself i still know that
there's a little
hole here i'm working on it like
that's why i'm still a student
that one was a little bit low right so
know your fault see your faults
you know everybody has an ego but at
least you can talk to yourself
don't worry about it and try to correct
the best you can
i said earlier in one of the other
about don't bring the elbow up
this one applies the same way
[Music]
so
the two stances can be
here like a type or you can turn
a little more
a little more or
some teachers do it this way some this
one
it's a preference thing again
it allows you to go further in your ski
i actually prefer it but many years ago
[Music]
i used to do it sideways now
i actually prefer to turn a little more
this is safe nowhere near your face
okay so uh they they're coming on
only one more and then that will finish
this uh
series of menuchi
it's called gyaku yokomin you share this
skin
yoka man there is no such thing really
as a yokoman but because the power of
the hips
is coming through powerful it um it
looks like it comes off the side of your
head
so but all the strikes are straight
really
but the power of the hips and the higher
you become in rank the more powerful
your hips become
and therefore this sort of like slicing
comes more so we could say that there's
a yokomin cut
but cytosensei used to say there's no
such thing as a yokemen cut
but there is no reason
okay thank you for your time